welcome back in this video we'll talk
about how to compute derivatives for you
to infinite gradient descent for
logistic regression the key takeaways
will be what you need to implement that
are the key equations you need in order
to implement gradient descent for
logistic regression but in this video I
want to do this computation using the
computation graph I have to admit using
the computation graph is a little bit of
an overkill for deriving gradient
descent for logistic regression but I
want to start explaining things this way
to get you familiar with these ideas so
that hopefully you'll make a bit more
sense when we talk about full fledged
neural networks
but so that does dive into gradient
descent for logistic regression to recap
we had set up logistic regression as
follows your predictions y hat is
defined as follows where Z is that and
if we focus on just one example for now
then the loss or respect to that one
example is defined as follows where a is
the output of the just regression and Y
is the ground truth label so let's write
this out as a computation graph and for
this example let's say we have only two
features x1 and x2 so in order to
compute Z we'll need to input w1 w2 and
B in addition to the feature values x1
x2 so these things in a computation
graph get used to compute Z which is w1
x1 plus w2 x2 plus B draw rectangle box
around that and then we compute Y hat or
a equals Sigma of Z that's the next step
in a computation Draft and then finally
we compute L a Y and I won't copy the
formula again so in logistic regression
what we want to do is to modify the
parameters W and B in order to reduce
this loss
we've described before propagation steps
of how you actually compute the loss on
a single training example now let's talk
about how you can go backwards to talk
to compute the derivatives here's the
cleaned up version of the diagram
because what we want to do is compute
derivatives respect to this loss the
first thing we want to do we're going
backwards is to compute the derivative
of this loss with respect to the script
over there with respect to this variable
a and so in the code you know you just
use da right to denote this um variable
and it turns out that if you often
believe of calculus you can show that
this ends up being negative Y over a
plus one minus y over one minus a and
the way you do that is you take the
formula for the loss and if you have a
bit of calculus you can compute the
derivative with respect to the variable
lowercase a and you get this formula but
if you're not familiar of calculus don't
worry about it we'll provide the
derivative formulas you need throughout
this course so if you are next to in
calculus you'll encourage you to look up
the formula for the loss from their
previous slide and try to get director
for respect to a using you know calculus
but if you don't know enough calculus to
do that don't worry about it
now having computed this quantity or da
the derivative of your final output
variable respect to a you can then go
backwards and it turns out that you can
show DZ which this is the Python code
variable name this is going to be you
know the derivative of the loss versus
back to Z or for L you can really write
the loss including a and y explicitly as
parameters or not alright give either
type of notation is equally acceptable
they can show that this is equal to a
minus y um just a couple comments only
for those of you did are explain experts
in calculus if you're not explain
calculus don't worry about it but it
turns out that this right DL DZ this can
be expressed as DL da time
da DZ um and it turns out that da DZ
this turns out to be a times 1 minus a
and D l da we are previously worked out
over here and so if you take these two
quantities you know DL da which is this
term together with da DZ which is this
term and just take these two things and
multiply them you can show that you the
equation simplifies the a minus y so
that's how you derive it and this is
really the chain rule that I pre-cleared
you did to inform ok so feel free to go
through that calculation yourself if you
are knowledgeable calculus but if you
aren't all you need to know is that you
can compute DZ as a minus y and it
already done the calculus for you and
then the final step in back propagation
is to go back to compute how much you
need to change W and B so in particular
you can show that the derivative respect
to w1 and in Co will call this DW 1 that
this is equal to x1 times DZ
um and then similarly DW 2 which is how
much you want to change W 2 is X 2 times
DZ and be excuse me DB is equal to DZ so
if you want to do gradient descents with
respect to just this one example what
you will do is the following you would
use this formula to compute DZ and then
use these formulas to compute DW 1 DW 2
and DB and then you perform these
updates w1 gets updated w1 - learning
rate alpha times D w1 w2 gets updated
similarly and B gets set as B - the
learning rate times DB and so this will
be one step of grade with respect to a
single example so you've seen how to
compute derivatives and implement
gradient descent for logistic regression
with respect to a single training
example but to train divisions of
Russian model you have not just one
training example given entire training
set of M training examples so
in the next video let's see how you can
take these ideas and apply them to
learning not just from one example but
from an entire training set